well witnesses say soldiers in sudan
have shot dead at least five people at a
protest demanding an end to military
rule the qatar-based news network al
jazeera which had been covering the
demonstrations says its bureau chief has
been arrested the protests came after
the army set up a new ruling council
without any civilians on it it dissolved
the country's power sharing government
last month
[Applause]
they came in their thousands in defiance
of the military
across sudan the streets filled with
calls for democratic rule
they were met with violence from
security forces
protesters say live bullets were fired
this coup is demolishing the
constitution they arrest young people
just for calling for civilian rule and
democracy
we want prime minister abdallah hamduk
to be freed as well as all the
politicians ministers and activists
the prime minister is among those
detained in the october coup
demonstrators are demanding a new era in
sudanese politics as the military
tightens its grip
since 1956 this country was ruled by
three military people and they did not
change anything
we are way behind the rest of the world
we want democratic civilian rule
police deny firing at the demonstrators
but the injuries at hospitals say
otherwise
i was shot
it was in the back
there was another one just like me but
he died
god gave me some extra time
[Music]
people should not stop i was beaten but
i have to go back to protest tomorrow
it's good that i'm alive but i wanted to
be a martyr
i said goodbye before i left home
a sacrifice some see as necessary in
sudan's long struggle for democracy